le problème c'est quand vous changez de
ministère chaque fois que vous devenez
un petit peu compétent non
choisis une bâche le bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes ici ce soir car vous avez
arrêté la politique vous êtes désormais
chroniqueuse sur D8 coanimatrice ah la
nouvelle chaîne en clair du groupe
Canal+
Roselyne on vous a dit qu'à canal
l'ambiance était plutôt [__] et cocaïne
non mais ça va aller la ligne éditoriale
décalée de canal me convient très très
bien ex-ministre de l'écologie et du
développement durable
ex-ministre de la santé ex-ministre de
la solidarité de la cohésion sociale
le problème c'est quand vous changez de
ministère chaque fois que vous devenez
un petit peu compétent non
je dois reconnaître que c'est une
spécialité française moi quand j'ai pris
le poste de ministre des Affaires
sociales en 2010 j'étais le cinquième
ministre des Affaires sociales de
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est fou il y a qu'en
France que ça existe on assiste à des
conseillers européens nos collègues
européens ne se donnent même plus la
peine de se souvenir du nom du ministre
français ils savent qu'il va changer au
prochain conseil c'est pas la peine de
perdre du temps à connaître le type à
fréquenter alors Roselyne j'ai remarqué
un truc pendant toutes les périodes où
vous étiez ministre vous ne veniez pas
dans mes émissions moi j'étais très déçu
et ne me dites pas que vous étiez
débordé de travail vous étiez ministre
maintenant je suis libre on est ravi la
porte de la cage c'est ouverte et
l'oiseau il vole d'abord
vous n'êtes plus ministre j'avais perdu
les élections ça a été quoi la plus
grosse erreur de la campagne de prendre
Nicolas Sarkozy comme candidat donc je
pense que Nicolas Sarkozy était un
admirable président de la République
d'ailleurs je défends son bilan mordicus
mais je pense qu'il a choisi une ligne
éditoriale à sa campagne qui oui dans à
feu à 100 le brûlot que vous avez publié
juste après la défaite de la droite vous
jugiez la campagne désastreuse la faute
dites-vous aux amnes noires
c'est buisson Gayant mignon qui sont
d'après vous responsable de la
droitisation de Sarkozy oui ça a été le
président de la République d'avancer
social tout à fait considérable de Mute
j'ai maintenu alors qu'on était en crise
de la création du RSA et tout d'un coup
six mois avant les élections ils
changent de ligne mélodique en même
temps il a fini à quoi 800 000 voix de
l'an donc ça veut dire que dans la
dernière partie de la campagne le fait
de tenir le discours de l'extrême droite
ça a été relativement payant moi ne
partage pas cette analyse je pense que
nous avons été aidé par deux choses la
médiocrité de la campagne et surtout de
l'argumentation de François Hollande et
puis une certaine discipline de
l'électorat majorité qui justement
devant les incongries du discours de
Hollande on dit quand même on peut pas
voter pour ce type là alors dans votre
livre tout le monde en prenait pour son
grade vos pieds Rachida Rama gayno alors
lorsqu'on dit à Guéno vous êtes Roselyne
Bachelot pendant 24 heures que
faites-vous il répond je me suicide
quand même et il y a journaliste qui lui
a répondu je comprends qu'à l'idée de
redevenir Henri Guaino je vous suicidiez
quand la campagne en écrivant ce livre
vous savez que vous faites vos adieux à
la vie politique vous brûlez vos
vaisseaux d'une certaine façon vous
dites mon choix est irrévocable je
redeviens une citoyenne de base j'ai été
en politique actif pendant 30 ans j'ai
été élu la première fois en 1982 ce qui
est très curieux c'est que très souvent
on trouve que les carrières politiques
sont trop longues dans notre pays on a
raison d'ailleurs il y a qu'en France où
on est à la barre pendant 30-45 ans
comme François Mitterrand et tout d'un
coup quand quelqu'un dit j'arrête on dit
mais tu devrais pas mais comment tu as
encore un combat et alors j'aime bien
citer cette phrase de Clémenceau qui
disait la politique c'est comme un Mac
on a beaucoup de mal à monter dedans
quand on est dedans on est ballotté de
droite à gauche et en général on se
casse la gueule on en sortant et moi
j'ai décidé que je me casserai pas la
gueule alors vous allez déclarer mes
priorités ont changé ce qui me reste à
vivre ne devra être que du plaisir
je suis Lacanau freudienne je me méfie
toujours des gens qui disent qu'ils se
sacrifie pour les autres parce que en
général il leur faut durement payer
en même temps maintenant vous allez vous
défoncer la tronche et qui dit pop quoi
c'est déjà il est bien cette photo la
chanson qui chante dans trindspotting
est une de mes chansons préférées
est une citoyenne de base maintenant
donc tout est possible vous dites ayant
dessiné d'arrêter ma carrière politique
je ne me voyais pas rester cloîtré chez
moi assise devant la télé les pieds dans
une chaufferette à écouter question pour
un champion
il y a des stars qui sont passés à la
politique mais je crois que c'est la
première fois qu'une politique devient
une star de la télé oui mais il faut
reconnaître que des propositions ont été
faites très souvent pour faire de la
télévision en passant de l'autre côté
d'ailleurs pour les pilotes on vous
prenait souvent en disant exactement on
appelle Roselyne c'est réglé et
j'adorais ça vous décidez donc de
rejoindre le grand 8 l'émission de
Laurence Ferrari sur D8 en compagnie
d'Audrey Pulvar d'Elisabeth boste et de
Hapsatou Sy
vous voulez faire le Journal du hard
mais qu'elle n'a pas voulu
dommage ça aurait été très drôle alors
je vous prends comme marde
[Applaudissements]
c'est marrant c'est politique ils vont
faire de la télé est-ce que vous croyez
que Sarkozy va rejoindre l'équipe de
Morandini sur NRJ12
avec avec Sarkozy tout est possible donc
voilà chroniqueuse sur D8 vous allez
parler de tout et de rien je ne suis pas
chronique
sur D8 vous allez parler de tout et de
rien en essayant de faire rire les gens
comme quand vous étiez ministre
finalement oui
plaisanterie mise à part c'est un
magazine d'infos il y aura de la
politique avec notre regard de femme
d'une manière décalée et puis on parlera
aussi de futilité parce qu'il faut
parler des choses graves bien sûr mais
on peut parler de mode de culture de
cuisine de forme de santé d'éducation
des enfants
c'est lundi c'est lundi
vous avez les Mickey
alors vous avez déclaré cette émission
c'est un engagement à temps plein c'est
mon occupation principale en échange de
quoi faisait quand même demandé 20000
euros par mois j'ai rien demandé du tout
incapable de
négocierons de chaîne ne gagnent pas ça
vous êtes deux fois mieux payés quand
vous étiez ministre finalement c'est ça
c'est comme quoi vous êtes emmerdés avec
les affaires sociales pendant des années
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu